字幕: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさん こんにちは
今日はみなさんに
見せたいものがあって
ひとつ持ってきたものがあります
それはこのコンパスです
今日はここ難波に来る時に
このコンパスを使って
どっちだろう どっちだろうって
来てみました
でも普段 僕はコンパス使わなくて
スマホを使っています
スマホがあれば
今 世界中どこにいても
自分の居場所がわかり
好きな場所に行くことができます
ただ 目的地を決めるのは
スマホではなくて
ここ 心のコンパス 好奇心です
僕は３年前まで ２年半をかけて
世界一周をしていました
アイスランドという国に行き
地球の美しさに驚き
煮えたぎるマグマを見て
地球の強さに驚きました
そしてアフリカに行って
民族と出会い 文化の違いに触れ
これまで103の国々を旅してきました
そして最近では 南極に行きました
ペンギンを見に行ったわけじゃなくて
ここでマラソンをしてました
マラソンが終わって
「温泉があるよ」と言われて
連れて行かれたのが
南極の海でした
（笑）
本当に冷たくて
凍え死ぬかと思いました
もう一生やりません
最近１か月前は
キックボクシングにも挑戦しました
体重が15キロほど重い相手と対戦し
なんとか勝ちましたが
頭がめちゃくちゃ痛かったです
こんなことに挑戦していると
よくみんなに「そのエネルギーは
どこから来るの？」と言われます
それは 幸せを探すのが 好きだからです
僕は小さい頃 「幸せって何だろう？」
なんて考えたこともなかったけど
大人になるにつれて「幸せって
何だろう？」と考え始めました
誰かが言う幸せを追いかけたり
誰かの目や 誰かの言葉を気にして
やりたいことにチャレンジできずにいました
そんな僕にも 夢はありました
小学校からサッカーを続け
ずっとプロサッカー選手になると
思って生きていました
だけど高校に入り
サッカー部に入りませんでした
父親から「高校に入ったらレギュラーに
なれるか分からない」と言われ
僕もプロサッカー選手になれなかったら
どうしようと不安になり
言い訳をつくって 夢から逃げました
高校では勉強 頑張っていました
有名大学に行こうと思って
努力していたけど
どの学部に行っていいか 分からず
本当にやりたいことは何だろう？
そう思ったら サッカーしかありませんでした
なんでサッカーを辞めてしまったんだ？
僕はずっと後悔して毎日泣いてました
それからもう一度サッカーに関わりたい
スポーツに関わりたいと思い
スポーツ学科のある大学に入学しました
大学ではスポーツを学び
サッカーを教えたりしていたけど
自分がプレーしてしていた時ほどワクワクせず
だんだんとサッカーからも離れていきました
そして次は就職です
どんな企業に就職したらいいんだろう？
有名な企業？
それとも給料がいいところ？
就職したら 昇進して部長になって
いい給料もらって 結婚して
子供が産まれて 老後を過ごしていく
そう考えたら 僕の人生が
自分のものじゃないみたいでした
生きるって何だろう？
それがわからず 僕は大学の図書館に行き
『生きる意味』そんな本を読んでみたり
生きる意味が分からないから
今度は『死ぬ意味』っていう本を
読んでみました
そのとき 本当に悩んでいて
お風呂にいって頭を洗うと
髪の毛で真っ黒になってました
１日髪の毛何本を抜けるかを調べて
100本200本抜けるっていうことを知って
思春期かと思いました
でも本当に悩んでいて
その正解がわからず
もうやりたいことを
やるしかないんだと思い
僕はやりたいことを
ノートに書き出しました
綺麗な海が見たい
世界中に友達を作りたい
英語を話したい
もっと自分らしく輝きたい
それを見たときに 留学だと思いました
でもアメリカやイギリスじゃなくて
もっともっと知らない世界に行きたい
そう思って僕は南の島フィジーに
行くことを決めました
フィジーは 四国ほどの大きさです
とびっきり綺麗な
こんな青い海が広がっていて
世界にはこんな綺麗な海が
あるんだと僕は驚きました
そしてフィジーは
「世界一幸せな国」と呼ばれています
「あなたは幸せですか？」と聞いたときに
「はい」って答える人が
世界で一番多いと言われています
ちなみにフィジー人はこんな人です
これは交通整理をしている人なんですけど
めちゃくちゃ楽しそうじゃないですか？
ハイビスカスをつけて
踊りながら仕事をしていて
疲れたら後ろにあるコーラを飲んでいました
このときに僕は「仕事って辛くて
大変なものだ」と思ってたんですよ
だけどこれを見て「仕事って楽しんで
いいんだ」って初めて思いました
フィジーには「ケレケレ」
という文化があります
「お前の物は 俺のもの
でも俺の物も お前のもの」
ちょっと優しいジャイアンみたいです
（笑）
僕がホームステイしている時のこと
Tシャツが無くなって
どこだって探していると
子どもが外で着ていたり
バーでお酒を飲んでたら
知らない人が僕のお酒を飲んでたりしました
そして一番驚いたのが
バスを待っていた時のことです
僕がバスを待っていて
隣に友達のフィジー人がいて
その後ろに知らないフィジー人がいました
バスが来て僕が乗ってお金を払って
友達もお金を払いました
そして 知らないフィジー人が乗った時に
「僕 お金ないんです」って言ったんです
「じゃあ なんで並んでたの？」
と思いません?
そしたら友達のフィジー人が
払ってあげたんです
「え 何でお金払ったの？」って聞いたら
「僕 お金あるから」と言いました
でも彼 全然お金持ちじゃないんです
「じゃあ お金なくなったら
どうするの？」って聞いたら
「誰かが払ってくれるから
大丈夫 その時は」 って言いました
それって家族だったらありえるけど
知らない人同士でありえるって
凄くないですか？
僕はフィジーが国全体が
家族のように感じました
僕たち先進国が発展してきたことで
そぎ落としてしまった
何か大切な温かいものが
フィジーにはある気がしました
そして僕は もっともっと世界を見て
自分の幸せを見つけたいと
新しい夢が出来ました
大学を卒業してから
僕は３年間 日本で働きました
稼ぐって何だろう？ お金って何だろう？
仕事って何だろう？
僕は一度 稼いでみようと
不動産会社に就職しました
１年目は会社で でもビリでした
全然お金がなくて
月末は数百円しかなくて
毎日 牛丼を食べて
でもお味噌汁が飲みたいから
松屋しか行けませんでした
そして２年目になり
急に成績が１番になりました
そして月収がなんと
約200万円ぐらいになりました
お金を稼いでいて 銀座で働いていて
なんかかっこいい感じはする
安定した生活も送れるかもしれない
だけど死ぬ時に
何をしなかったら後悔するんだろう？
そう思ったときに
僕が思ったのは世界一周でした
もうサッカーをやめた時のような
後悔はしたくなかったんです
社会的にかっこいい自分じゃなくて
理想的な自分を生きたい
26歳にして僕は初めて
誰かが言った「いい」ではなく
自分の「好き」を選ぶことができました
仕事を辞めて
僕は自分の価値を自分で作っていくと
世界中で挑戦してきました
世界に出るからには
世界一を味わいたいと思い
僕は世界一過酷な
サハラマラソンに参加しました
このサハラマラソンなんですが
最高気温は55度です
そして距離はなんと 250キロです
僕は世界一過酷なマラソンに
世界一過酷な状況で出たいと思い
練習ゼロで 荷物15キロ背負って参加しました
でもみんなは１グラムでも
荷物を減らそうと努力してくるんですよ
例えばこの人 歯ブラシは
先端しか持ってこないんです
僕は歯ブラシ１本持ってきてるし
歯磨き粉も持ってきてるし
重い荷物 背負ってました
何よりきつかったのが
小さめの靴を履いてしまったことでした
３日目になると もう足がパンパンで
靴から足が出るんじゃないかぐらい
痛かったです
そして僕の隣の人なんて こんな足でした
足の爪が全部取れて
足の皮はめくれていました
でもこの人 完走するんです
サハラ砂漠は 地平線を何度越えても
地平線しかありませんでした
250キロ先のゴールなんて
全然見えませんでした
４日目５日目になると 足が棒のようでした
そのときに僕ができたことは
１ミリでも進むこと
１歩でも進むことでした
それだけを意識して進んでいました
そしたらなんと ゴールできたんです
しかも世界２位でした
下から数えてですが
（笑）
そんな僕も学んだことがあります
それは どんなに遠い
夢だったりゴールでも
今日１ミリでも１歩でも進んでたら
絶対にゴールに近づいてるってことです
僕はそれを学ぶことができました
そしてサハラマラソンを終えた後に
１週間後 ドイツに行きました
そしたら ドイツで
フルマラソンがあったんですよ
その日に参加できるって聞いて
僕は参加しました
そのときはすごく面白くて
スタート地点あるじゃないですか
そこにこう立った瞬間に
もうすぐゴールだって思ったんです
サハラマラソンの最終日みたいだし
荷物 背負わなくていいし
食料や水とかを その辺でくれるし
え これ一瞬じゃんって
そう思ったときに
自分が挑戦していくと
常識とか限界の幅がどんどん広がっていって
世界が面白くなっていきました
だけど旅していると
旅が日常にもなってきます
観光地に行くのが当たり前だし
美味しい食べ物はいつでも食べられるし
僕は一番感動したことはやっぱり
サハラマラソンを走り終えた時なんです
そして 一番美味しかったものは
サハラマラソンを走り終えた時のコーラでした
このときに僕が思ったのは
変えるのは旅の行き先じゃなくて
自分の生き方だ と思いました
自分日常を どう劇場にできるか？
僕はそこからまた旅を続けました
そしてキルギスという国に行った時に
ロバが買えるって噂を聞いて
それめっちゃロマンじゃんと思ったんですよ
ロバと旅したい
インターネットでロバの買い方って調べても
出てこなくて 旅した人がいなくて
じゃあもう「ロバを買いたい」
ってキルギス語で書いて
僕はそれをこう回って 村に行きました
そのときの動画があります
（音楽）
これはキチキミン村という村に行った時です
このときに初めてロバと出会いました
僕が買ったロバで 名前はミミちゃんです
ミミちゃんに鞍を付けて 荷物を載せて
冒険スタートしました
めちゃくちゃ冒険ぽくないですか？
（音楽終わり）
これがミミちゃんなんですけど
これいくらで買ったと思います？
最初これ10万円って言われたんですよ
でも旅人の僕は
「10万円じゃ買えないなぁ」と思って
「お願いもうちょっと安くして」と言ったら
なんと９千円で買えました
（笑）
安すぎじゃないですか？
このミミちゃん 何よりいいのが
めちゃくちゃ笑顔なんです
僕はもう最高のパートナーを
見つけたと思いました
それで もうサハラマラソンも走っているし
もう僕はどこまでも行けると思ったので
500キロ先の山の上をゴールにしました
そしてスタートして３時間が経ちました
３時間経って 進んだ距離が
なんと たったの50メートルだったんです
全然進んでなくてミミちゃんが
もうこんな状態になってしまいました
このままだとヤバいと思って
先にミミちゃんより自分が餓死すると思って
村に戻って水を買いに行きました
そしたら村人に「今日うちで
ごはん食べていきなよ」って言われて
「分かった でもミミちゃんいるから
ちょっと連れてくるね」って
ミミちゃんのとこ 戻ったんですよ
そしたらミミちゃんに逃げられてて
しかも荷物ごと無かったんです
（笑）
でこれやばいなと思って その日も探して
次の日も探してもいなくて
僕は少しのお金とパスポートしか
持ってなかったんです
ずっと村を彷徨っていると
急におばちゃんに来い来い来いと言われて
家の中にドーンと入れられました
そこは６畳１間ぐらいの大きさの家で
そこには７人の娘息子がいました
いきなり「お前が今日から
ここの長男だ」と言われて
僕はそこに10日間 住み始めました
ジャスミンと一緒に朝 水を汲みに行ったり
昼はジャシーと一緒にトウモロコシを刈ったり
夜はお母さんと一緒にパンを作っていました
まるで本当の家族のように
可愛がってくれました
このときに僕はこれが本当の
旅なんだなって思ったんです
やりたい事があったら そこに道がなくても
自分で道を作っていく
それができたら 世界中どこにいても
自分らしい旅ができるんだと思いました
僕は今 幸せです
そしてもっともっと幸せを
探していきたいと思っています
そしていろんな人と一緒に
幸せを味わいたいと思っています
今 僕は「世界一周学校」という
コミュニティを作っていて
キャンピングカーで日本を回ったり
キックボクシングや
フットサルの部活を作ったり
一緒に世界中 旅に行っています
学校を卒業してからも
こうやっていろんな仲間と一緒に
挑戦して楽しむことができて
僕はすごく幸せです
最後に 幸せを探す上で大切だと
思っていることをお伝えします
それは 好奇心というコンパスを
壊さないでください
好奇心のコンパスが壊れると
何をしていいか分からなくなります
誰かの常識やルールがないと
人生を選べなくなってしまいます
僕は昔 言われました
「海外に行ったから成功するわけじゃない」
だけど そこに一歩を踏み出してみると
新しい出会いがあったり
応援してくれる人がいたり
支えてくれている人がいたり
一緒に挑戦してくれる人がいたり
幸せがどんどん増えてきました
「海外に行ってみたい」
たった一つの小さな好奇心が
僕を世界中に連れてってくれました
だからみなさんも 好奇心の
コンパスを信じてみてください
なんかいいなとか
なんか好きだなとか
そういったものがあったら
やってみてください
そして心が楽しいとか
嬉しいとか感じたら
それを大切にしてください
そしたら 少しずつやりたいことが
見つかってくると思います
そしてやりたいことをやり遂げ
自分との約束を果たしていったら
それが自信になります
もし夢を諦めて後悔してる人がいたら
やりたいことがあって
まだできていない人がいたら
ぜひ一歩を踏み出してみてください
きっと 誰もが想像したこともない
正解があります
人生はいつも 今がスタート地点です
ありがとうございました
（拍手）